well good afternoon thanks senator
Murphy my job I think for the rest of
the panel here is to be kind of a setup
man to kind of make keep my remarks
broad enough so that it provides the
kind of umbrella for the speakers that
come after me so there won't be too many
surprises here but I hope to start off
with a broad discussion of some of the
impacts on New England now I'm a long
term New England resident proud to be so
I don't think we live in one of the most
dangerous areas of the world by any
means we don't have the fires that
California has we don't have the floods
that Colorado has this week but we have
our own hazards just to remind you a bit
about our little corner of the world we
live in a fairly mountainous area the
mountains increase the precipitation
over the region and channel that
precipitation in two rivers that
increase the possibility of flooding we
have a distribution of deciduous trees
you say on the left the red indicates
where the deciduous trees live in New
England and they play a great role in
our climate in terms of evaporating
enhancing the evaporation of soil water
and moistening the atmosphere especially
in the so-called leaf out season
basically from mid-march until
mid-october we also have agriculture
it's shrinking the red areas on the
right side there indicate where you
still have traditional agriculture going
on in New England the way these are both
as detected from from Earth orbiting
satellites so this is the broad view
this is a kind of universe in which we
live here in New England and in addition
we have the storms I think Kerry's going
to talk much more about the storms but
basically if you ask a meteorologist
what's special about New England whether
they'll almost always bring up these two
points first of all in the upper left we
are at a location of converging storm
tracks we get winter storms that start
up in Alberta the so-called Alberta
Clippers we get winter storms at
starting Colorado and come east towards
our location and most infamous
are the Nor'easters that start down in
in the Gulf of Mexico or up along the
Carolina coastline and come up from the
south and causes a variety of storms
here in New England and then of course
in the summertime we get the tropical
cyclones that come up out of the
tropical North Atlantic and impact us so
we are kind of in a crossfire here in
new england between these different
kinds of storms so you can put together
a list this isn't a scientist list this
is just a new england residence list i
mean i've experienced a lot of these
things myself and so have you we get the
winner blizzards and Nor'easters and
there are some of the dates recent and
not so recent when there have been
notable storms of this kind we get
hurricanes that hit New England the
great New England hurricane of 1938 was
perhaps the most famous but now of
course we look to Irene and Sandy from
last year we get ice storms where you
get the supercooled water falling on the
landscape destroying trees and power
lines we get heat waves including one
from this summer I'm sure you remember
that severe convection and tornadoes and
of course air pollution events what we
want to do is to find out which of these
are might get worse which ones might get
better as we pass into the next 20 40 60
80 100 years and that's part of what the
panel will be talking about today
there's been quite a bit of literature
on this a growing literature here are
some covers from a few reports all
fairly recent the earliest one of course
is the IPCC report there which is 2007
and just about 10 days from now we
expect the next version of that report
we're all excited to see it come out
except to be honest with you we know
most of what's in it because the way the
protocol on the IPCC reports works is it
it reports mostly on work that's already
been published in peer-reviewed journals
so in fact those of us that read those
journals have a pretty good idea of what
the new IPCC report is going to change
is going to say only some of the final
conclusions are unknown to us but a lot
of good work has been going on and as
Mark indicated Yale is going to get
involved in this kind of work as well
and I think we can make a real
contribution to it I'm going to pull a
few diagrams out of some of these
reports to show you what we expect over
the next few years this comes from this
will probably be in the new IPCC report
and it is the expected surface
temperature change globally frumpy Ann
pre-industrial to the end of the current
century according to the high emission
scenario so with all those words there
let me just point out what you need to
know about this the scale is rather
impressive all by itself it's in degrees
celsius and the deep reds go up into the
457 even 11 degrees celsius and those in
the back might be able to see maybe it's
possible to darken the light on the
screen but New England rather in the
wintertime December January February has
a rather remarkable localized warming
that gets up into the five to seven even
almost 10 degrees Celsius under this
extreme emission scenario called RCP 85
which I can talk more about if there are
questions but that's certainly one of
the things we're keeping an eye and I'm
going to be emphasizing that they've
also done these simulations using
climate models for the summer months and
we see extraordinary warming's as well
especially again in high latitudes and
in New England not quite as large as as
in the winter time but still
extraordinarily temp extraordinary
temperature increases in this part of
the world the modelers also produce
forecasts of precipitation here in the
wintertime December January February we
find notable increases in precipitation
in New England with somewhat high
confidence in other words the different
models that have run been running on
this issue seem to agree that in the
wintertime we're going to be getting
more Pacific
in the wintertime in the summertime
however it's not so clear if you can
work this out it takes a while to do so
these diagrams are complicated but
basically New England shows up either in
the no change or in the disagreement
area which means the models don't agree
very well but what they all agree on is
that the increased temperatures will
cause increase evaporation rates that'll
be the big impact for New England water
wise but with the increased evaporation
rates in the summertime so just a word
or two about what this temperature rise
will do for New England more heat waves
and a greatly increased power demand for
air conditioning we saw that this summer
warmer winters with less snow the seeing
industry will be going out of business
longer leaf out season the leaves will
come out earlier and especially stay
longer in the fall that means more
evaporation less of a snowmelt pulse
down the rivers and in the winter time
in the summertime already New England
rivers tend to dry out that will be
greatly enhanced in the future most of
the rivers you're familiar with will get
quite dry in the summer time warming
lake in coastal waters that has an
impact on power generation and sea life
changing ecosystems insects invasive
plants shifting forests and vector-borne
diseases degrading air quality because
temperature plays a role in the
conversion of primary pollutants to
damaging ozone concentrations and
finally the agriculture is going to be
hit both for better and for worse longer
growing seasons but many crops will be
impaired by heat drought and insects
here's the one I don't like to see this
is the frequency of heat waves days over
on two degrees Fahrenheit today it's
only a few excuse me today it's only a
few days a year at the end of the
century it could be a good fraction of
the summer especially in the high
emission cereal scenario but even in the
low emission scenario many more days of
very high temperatures here in
Connecticut this one's for heart
I like this diagram I got it from one of
those New England reports it shows us in
New England skipping southwards
essentially as the climate warms this
isn't this is a little bit sloppy it's
not doesn't have the whole picture but
in general in terms of mean summer
temperatures this shows that by the end
of the century in the high emission
scenario will be basically Georgia and
South Carolinians here here in perhaps
not politically I hope but at least at
least climate wise and what about the
force our beloved forests here in
Connecticut really a dramatic change and
this shows I won't go through this in
detail but it shows the current state of
the force especially the maple elm and
beech forests are going to largely
disappear the pine forests will be gone
I'm sorry the spruce forest will be gone
and we'll have a very different makeup
of forests to wrap up just a word or two
about about sea level rise this is the
older forecast for sea level rise by the
year 2100 only about that much or so but
now the new forecasts are getting to be
the order of almost twice that that's
probably the biggest change between the
last IPCC report and the new one is a
degree of sea level rise what will that
do for New England well the course
little flood areas these are the these
are the high-water marks mostly from
Hurricane sandy for for New Haven
Connecticut but one other thing that we
don't think so much about but as sea
level rises that influence comes inland
as well and it comes inland in two ways
if you're is sea level that controls the
intrusion of salt water into the land
and it also controls at least if you're
within five or ten miles of the
shoreline it controls the water table as
well so as sea level rises this curve
rises and so does the water table and
that means for example here in New Haven
these
some recent calculations by the USGS
that if the water in the sound Rises so
we'll groundwater in the city of New
Haven and the surrounding coastal areas
and that has a great impact on all
underground structures including
foundations of buildings subways
everything you put below ground is going
to be influenced by this rising sea
level even if you're not at the coast
and even if you're not experiencing a
storm and a storm surge I've gone over
my time so I'll leave it there and thank
you